they all say this but i literally she
said i had a wonderful nurse called lily
and she said you're going to feel the
sharps
i literally did not feel a thing and so
it was very good uh very quick and
you know what i'm going to say i cannot
recommend it too highly
everybody when you do get your
notification to go for a jab please go
and get it it is
the best thing for you best thing for
your family and for everybody else
thanks very much
all the corporate everybody effects
however rare they might be yeah i really
don't i think you should listen
don't just listen to me listen to all
the scientists listen to what the
european
medicines agency had to say yesterday to
what the
the mhra has said
the risk is covered this is a this is a
great thing to do thank you all very
much thank you
they're from the uh prime minister boris
johnson talking of his wonderful nurse
lily who has just given him his first
dose of the astroved seneca vaccine
interesting enough going back uh to
saint thomas's hospital the prime
minister there
pretty much this time last year i think
it was april the 5th last year
that's when boris johnson was admitted
to intensive care for three nights
at that hospital i think a little longer
in in total
after getting very poorly at one point
from suffering of course you remember
rightly from covid19
at that time